händewaschen und abstand zu halten
ich bin etwas aufgeregt für diese für
diesen ersten schultag endlich seinen
eigenen ängste weil man sich wieder
andere menschen her schulstart im
ausnahmezustand
und das weltweit super special events
sollen unbedingt vermieden werden
kann das funktionieren wir sind dabei
von thailand bis dänemark und von den
usa bis schottland h das leben im süden
von dänemark hier lebt eine große
deutsche gemeinde auch nele morgen mein
name ist nicht ganz ich lebe in
süddänemark und arbeitet als lehrerin an
der schule für nele grenz geht es heute
wieder los sie unterrichtet eine dritte
klasse
nele ist aufgeregt wie kommen die
schülerinnen mit den neuen regelungen
klar einen weiteren lockdown will sie
nicht erleben
es war schwierig weil man nicht wusste
was kommt das wusste keiner aber die
kinder waren sehr gut darin das zu
akzeptieren
ich habe mich dann doch gefreut als es
dann wieder hieß dass die schüler dürfen
schule unter corona bedingungen dh in
dänemark vor allem viele hände waschen
zu lehrer und schüler eine masken
pflicht gibt es nicht
nele versuch so lange es geht den
unterricht im freien abzuhalten
die kinder sind einfach froh dass sie
wieder in die schule dürfen wie war
schule als crooner war als wir nicht in
die schule kommen dürfen nicht es war
komisch oder ja ja wir haben wir das
denn gemacht mit schuber haarscharf
gaben hausaufgaben haben wir haben wir
auch miteinander gesprochen dass man ja
ich habe viel mit - gesprochen haben wie
habt ihr das gemacht über computer für
nele ist eines in der korona zeit
besonders wichtig dass man sich ja mal
wieder anstrengend das beste aus der
situation zu machen und sie jetzt als
lehrkraft ganz besonders besonders gut
machen möchte für karl für die schüler
wie funktioniert schule in dem land mit
den meisten infizierten weltweit in der
nähe von las vegas lebt und unterrichtet
die highschool lehrerinnen tosca arts
sie ist vor sieben jahren aus
deutschland in die usa gezogen und lebt
hier mit ihrem mann einem soldaten im
ruhestand und ihren drei kindern sechs
monate waren sie jetzt alle zu hause
seit einer woche hat oskar wieder dienst
eigenen ängste weil man sich wieder
andere menschen
deswegen müssen sie hier überall eine
maske tragen
die schulleiterin hat den start um zwei
wochen verschoben weil die lehrkräfte
auf das neue e learning programmen
geschult werden müssen
denn sollte die schule wegen corona
schließen müssen will man vorbereitet
sein
wir planen darauf hin dass wenn wir
wieder auf komplett distance-learning um
schwanken müssen dass dann alle schüler
bereit sind von zu hause erfolgreich
unterrichtet zu werden so das heißt alle
schüler werden jetzt geschult diese
plattform zu benutzen
in der schule und auch schauen daheim
die parrot high school ist eine
öffentliche schule und hat sich für eine
mischung aus homeschooling und
präsenzunterricht entschieden eine
ausnahme in den usa entscheiden
teilweise die 13.600 schul distrikte
selbst welche regelungen gelten jeder
district hat eine andere strategie
chaotische zustände im schulwesen für
tosca kaum zu ertragen präsenzunterricht
sei für viele schüler hier immens
wichtig wir haben sehr viele finanziell
schwache familien
wir haben einen sehr hohen anteil an
pflegefamilien die kinder aufnehmen so
dass auch der sozioökonomische status
einfach nicht gewährleistet ist für
viele schüler von der heim produktiv zu
arbeiten
chong wei im norden thailands
eines der wichtigsten kulturellen und
wirtschaftlichen zentren des landes
david stüber ist 17 jahre alt lebt hier
mit seinen eltern und startet heute in
sein letztes schuljahr vor dem abitur
dass es so aussehen würde hätte er sich
wohl nie vorstellen können für 200
kinder und jugendliche startet die
christlich deutsche schule mit einem
eröffnungsgottesdienst ins neue jahr
heute war der erste normalen schultag in
anführungszeichen und anführungszeichen
nur weil einige lehrer noch fehlen auch
schüler fehlen noch
dh der schulalltag kann nur bedingt
normal weitergehen
die strengen vorgaben der thailändischen
regierung müssen umgesetzt werden
fieber messen am eingang maske auf dem
schulgelände und trennwände mit
plastikfolien im klassenzimmer
trotz der ganzen einschränkungen david
ist froh endlich wieder in die schule
gehen zu können
und natürlich fehlen auch die sozialen
kontakte so ich meine dieses zwischen
den stunden mit seinen freunden was
machen das fehlt einem schon wenn man
nun der quarantänezeit alleine für sich
arbeitet klar über facetime und so kann
man schon ganz viel machen mit freunden
aber es ist halt nicht das gleiche
thailand hatte die pandemie von anfang
an gut im griff die regierung
veranlasste gleich zu beginn einen
strengen lockdown und einen ein
reisestopp nahezu überall gelten strikte
hygieneregeln und auch deswegen ist die
zahl der infizierten mit 3300 corona
fällen sehr niedrig
im unterschied zu anderen ländern weil
die korona anlage in deutschland im
moment nicht so gut aussieht und
thailand strenge einreise regeln hat hat
david für sich einen entschluss gefasst
ich gehe in die fünfte klasse und werden
dieses jahr mein abitur machen
deswegen werde ich auch an weihnachten
wahrscheinlich nicht nach deutschland
fliegen einfach um das risiko nicht zu
haben das sich vielleicht nicht zurück
nach thailand kommen
seine eltern sind zwar auch beide in
thailand aber seine oma und seinen opa
und den rest der familie wird er
vermutlich erst 2021 wiedersehen nach
seinem letzten schultag und dann
hoffentlich mit abitur zürich in der
schweiz einer von 26 kantonen und alle
haben unterschiedliche corona regeln
philipp petzschner ist deutschlehrer
hier am gymnasium seine klasse trifft er
heute zum ersten mal
ich bin etwas aufgeregt für diese für
diesen ersten schultag war es
schülerinnen und schüler sind die ich
noch nicht kenne weil ich mir auch nicht
ganz vorstellen kann wie das mit masken
und ganzen klassen abständen
funktionieren sollte abstände gibt es
später im klassenzimmer dann eher nicht
auch masken müssen die schüler hier
nicht tragen bei einer infektion greift
das contact racing philipp wampfler ist
es freigestellt ob und wann er eine
maske trägt heute am ersten schultag hat
er da noch keine einheitliche linie
gefunden
der erste schultag ist immer ein
bisschen anstrengend und die ganze zeit
sich überlegen muss ich jetzt die maske
anziehen und dass sie wieder abnehmen
damit nicht die klasse gut versteht und
mich dahinter diese plastik trennwand zu
stellen das hat schon etwas nerven
gekostet habe insgesamt habe ich ein
gutes gefühl doch vielleicht ein
trügerisches die korona zahlen in der
schweiz sind zuletzt kontinuierlich
angestiegen
auch durch reiserückkehrer über 16.000
menschen sind deswegen in quarantäne
auch ein risiko an schulen bei einem
ausbruch müsste dann der kanton
entscheiden wie es weitergeht
in kopenhagen ist auf stehzeit bei
familie es für die beiden töchter luana
und leonie geht es nach langen
homeschooling wochen und ferien wieder
zurück in die schule
die motivation könnte größer sein
fertigmachen okay die familie lebt erst
seit einem jahr in kopenhagen der job
von vater jörg brachte sie in die
dänische hauptstadt mutter tanja
arbeitet nach wie vor drei tage die
woche in deutschland familie pendeln und
homeschooling während corona eine
gewaltige herausforderung als das ganze
mit corona an
da war ich schon ziemlich gefordert weil
ich musste er auch gucken wie ich das
mit meinem beruf brach aber auch mit der
schule und da hat man insbesondere von
der schule und von den lehrern und den
anderen eltern von verschiedenen kanälen
informationen erhalten die man dann
versucht hat zusammen zu sammeln um es
dann den kindern weiterzugeben
doch jetzt ist zum glück wieder schule
tanja bringt leoni und luana zweimal die
woche mit dem fahrrad dorthin den rest
der woche arbeitet sie in deutschland
auch in dänemark steigen die zahlen an
knapp 2.000 neue fälle gab es in den
vergangenen zwei wochen
deswegen sind die schulen vorsichtig
eltern wie tanja dürfen die kinder nur
bis 100 meter vor die schule bringen
dann müssen
anna und leonie alleine weiter und ich
will euch dann ab von der schule wieder
okay so vergeht nicht an die ecke zu
gehen und leonie sind froh dass die
schule wieder offen ist
in einem neuen land freunde finden die
sprache lernen das alles geht zu hause
nicht so gut
am anfang waren wir das richtig cool und
lacht
auch die schule können wir gut
verzichten also es frauen dass ich dann
halt als länger gedauert hat haben wir
irgendwie entzugserscheinungen nach der
schule gekriegt weil wir einfach
vermisst habe mit anderen leuten
zusammen zu sein
in kohden bis nördlich von edinburgh
beginnt an der highschool wieder der
unterricht
ein paar kilometer entfernt laufen die
vorbereitungen für den ersten schultag
bei der 15-jährigen iden mitchell auf
hochtouren
sie nimmt ihre morgen routine wieder auf
ich habe mich gerade fertig vorbereitet
und meiner schwester frühstück gemacht
jetzt packe ich meinen rucksack also
land wasser und snacks für die pause
dann gehe ich an der beef highschool
fühlen sie sich gewappnet
schilder ermahnen zum abstandhalten was
dann bei der ankunft der schüler
überhaupt nicht funktioniert 1300
schüler im zaum zu halten nahezu
unmöglich ihnen hat heute eigentlich
sport doch den gibt es wegen corona nur
als theorieunterricht schottland hatte
die pandemie verglichen mit england früh
gut im griff 600 neue fälle gab es in
den vergangenen zwei wochen trotzdem es
ist noch ein abtasten hier für lehrer
und schülerinnen der erste schultag war
echt super jetzt wenn ich gerade ins
auto gestiegen und wir holen meine
schwester ab es war echt gut ich habe
mich wirklich sicher gefühlt
mama was sagst du dazu ich bin so froh
dass du wieder in die schule gehst das
wurde allerhöchste zeit
das stimmt online unterricht war hart es
einfach zu schaffen als fertigte
bekommen sich wirklich persönlich zu
sehen ist einfach motivieren man lernt
so viel mehr wenn man in die schule geht
[Musik]
ein satz den wohl fast alle eltern
lehrer und schüler so unterschreiben
würden und zwar weltweit
von dänemark bis thailand und von den
usa bis schottland